So, so, uh, so listener, this is a, this is a threesome intro, um, and we just, well, I think it's, uh, it's, it's safer to call it that so that there's no, there's no surprises. Um, you know, let's label it as dangerous as possible. Let's establish some rules and then enjoy the threesome. You know, should we say, should we say our names in the threesome? It's better not to know your names. Um, what would your, what would your safe word be? Well, let's just start by cutting all these lights.
所以，呃，听众朋友们，这是一个，这是一个三人组合的开场，呃，我们刚刚，好吧，我觉得，呃，叫这个名字比较安全，这样就不会有，就不会有什么惊喜了。呃，你知道的，把它贴上尽可能危险的标签。让我们先立下一些规矩，然后好好享受这个三人行。你知道，我们该不该说，我们在三人行里该不该说出各自的名字？最好还是别知道你们的名字。呃，那你的，你的安全词会是什么？好吧，我们就从关掉所有灯开始吧。
Um, I, I just know that darkness is usually the best. You just let whatever happens happen. Yeah. My safe word is chicken and waffles. Chicken and waffles. Okay. And this is very dark in here now. This is great.
呃，我，我只知道黑暗通常是最好的。你只需要顺其自然就行了。对。我的安全词是“炸鸡配华夫饼”。炸鸡配华夫饼。好的。现在这里面黑漆漆的。这感觉太棒了。
Okay. And I will just, mine will be Constantinople. And what about yours friend with the, ooh, that's Hansy. Is that you? I'm done. You're already finished. Huh. Well, then let's get to the show.
好的，那我的，我的就是“君士坦丁堡”。那你的呢，那个朋友，哦，那是汉茜。是你吗？我不干了。你已经录完了？哈。好吧，那咱们开始吧。
Here's smart. Let's start. Smart. Smart. Now you were going to say something of great importance. No, I just said I have two openers. I could tell you about my colonoscopy. Or I could, we could talk about Scotty's birthday today.
听好了。我们开始。听好了。听好了。刚才你打算说一件非常重要的事情。不，我只是说我有两个开场白。我可以跟你聊聊我的肠镜检查。或者我可以，我们可以聊聊斯科特今天的生日。
Oh, what do you mean two openers? Are you two openers? Do you think about what you're going to talk about before we come on air? Well, just before I came on, I was like, oh, it's Scotty's birthday. And I wanted to tell you about my colonoscopy. Well, first of all, you don't have to call them openers. Okay. First of all, I know you hate that jet.
哦，什么叫两个开场白？你们有两套开场白吗？在开播之前，你们会想好要聊些什么吗？好吧，就在我上节目之前，我心想，哦，今天是斯科特的生日。我还想跟你聊聊我的肠镜检查。好吧，首先，你不用管它们叫开场白。好吧。首先我知道你讨厌那个，杰特。
You hate that. If you can't, guys, let's not fight already. Let me just say this. If you can't decide whether to talk about your husband's birthday, your colonoscopy, then you guys, you guys are a rubble. They are synonymous. Well, they're very... I mean...
你讨厌那个。伙计们，如果你们不能，咱们先别吵了。我只想说这个。如果你无法决定是聊你老公的生日，还是聊你的肠镜检查，那你们俩，你们俩简直就是一堆废墟。它们俩根本是一回事。好吧，它们非常……我是说……
Anyway, well... When was your colonoscopy? How did it go? Can we pick? Well, colonoscopy is really fast. I mentioned this to Jason the other day and he's like, you got to tell us in the pocket. So when I had earlier this summer, I had my colonoscopy and I was like, I got to think of something right before I go under.
不管怎样，好吧……你的肠镜检查是什么时候做的？过程怎么样？我们能挑一个说吗？好吧，肠镜检查其实很快。我前几天跟杰森提过这事，他说：“你得在播客里跟大家说说。”所以今年夏天早些时候，我做了肠镜检查，当时我在想，我得在麻醉生效前想个段子。
And so... Why do you have to think of it? Because you want to entertain the group. I just want to go out on a joke. Go out on a joke. In case you don't come back, you want to be able to do the last thing that you made doctors laugh. Yeah, I got it.
然后……你为什么非得想个段子？因为你想逗大家开心啊。我只想用一个笑话收场。用一个笑话收场。万一你醒不过来，你想留下能让医生笑出来的最后一句。对，我懂。
I think you thought about an opener for today, so you were thinking about a closer for your colonoscopy. Keep going. And now Chew. Go ahead, Sean. And Chew. No. So, you know, I was in the little operating room.
我想你之前是在为今天的节目想开场白，结果你满脑子想的都是你肠镜检查的收场白。继续说吧。现在，咀嚼。说下去，肖恩。一边去。不。所以呢，你知道的，当时我躺在那个小手术室里。
There was like two nurses at the doctor, the anesthesiologist, whatever, and you're on your side with your ass hanging out, bare ass. And I go, let me know when the propofol goes and you know the anesthesia. And they go, okay, it's going in. I go, and they go, count backwards from 10. And I go, 10, nine, whatever you do, don't touch my asshole, and then I was out. And did you ask for a review of your joke when you woke up? Great question.
里面大概有两个护士和一个医生，还有麻醉师什么的，然后你侧躺着，屁股露在外面，光着屁股。我对他们说：“等丙泊酚起效的时候告诉我一声，你知道的，就是麻醉。”他们说：“好的，药正在注入。”我说，他们说：“从10开始倒数。”我说：“10，9，不管你做什么，绝对别碰我的菊花，”然后我就不省人事了。当你醒过来的时候，你有没有要求他们对你的笑话做个点评？问得好。
Did it work? Nobody cared. But did they laugh? I think I heard a couple of chuckles as I was leaving. Don't you touch my ass. Imagine the jokes they get. I know, I can't even. Imagine the jokes that accountants decide to make in those moments.
管用吗？根本没人理。但他们笑了吗？我离开的时候好像听到几声偷笑。别碰我的屁股。想象一下他们平时听到的那些笑话吧。我懂，我简直无法想象。想象一下会计师们在那种时刻会决定讲什么笑话。
We're Sean. We're Sean. I remember being real lippy when I woke up and still kind of somewhat inebriated from the, from the anesthesia. I made, I made some, some, some inappropriate jokes to the doctor there. He's a professional. Don't you sleep really well after that though? I love it.
我们是肖恩。我们是肖恩。我记得我醒来的时候嘴皮子可利索了，而且还带着麻醉带来的那种微醺的状态。我跟那里的医生开了几个，几个，几个不太合时宜的玩笑。他可是个专业人士。不过做完那个之后你真的睡得很香，对吧？我太喜欢了。
Yeah. So how were things? Did, did they, did they chop anything out? Everything's fine. Everything's, he said, you might want to think about losing a couple of pounds, but other than that. No, he didn't. Did he really?
对啊。那情况怎么样？他们，他们，他们有切掉什么东西吗？一切都挺好的。一切都，他说：“你可能得考虑减掉那么一两磅，”除此之外。没有，他真这么说？
Yeah. Yeah. I had an endoscopy too and he, I have like a tiny, what does that mean? It was something through the mouth. You know, they look down your throat to look at your stomach as well as your asshole. Did the two cameras meet somewhere in the middle or like to run your stomach? Did they go, hello? Yeah.
对啊。对啊。我还做过胃镜，他，我有一个很小的，那是什么意思？那是个从嘴里伸进去的玩意儿。你知道的，他们会顺着你的喉咙看你的胃，当然也包括你的菊花。那两根摄像头有没有在中间某个地方汇合，或者说从你的胃里穿过去？它们会说，你好吗？对。
We got coverage. We got coverage. Did they have a special camera that can get through chin chin, food, lay in the stomach, that can burrow? Scratch through a few dumplings. Yeah. What? Yeah.
拍到了。拍到了。他们有没有那种特殊的摄像头，能够穿过下巴、食物、躺在胃里的东西，还能打洞？钻透几个饺子。 yeah。什么？yeah。
No. Anyway. How is hydrohypochondriac are going? Good. Really well. I feel like we're on an episode right now. I know. Forget it.
不。不管怎样。恐病症患者近况如何？很好。真的很好。我觉得我们现在就像在拍一集节目。我懂。算了吧。
Let's move on. No, let's not move on. Let's move on to your husband's birthday. Yeah. No, it's good. Thank you very much. Would you, would you get Scotty for his birthday? So I got him.
我们继续吧。不，我们别继续这个了。我们来聊聊你老公的生日吧。对。不，挺好的。非常感谢。你，你送了斯科特什么生日礼物？所以，我送了他。
You guys, you love this. I got him some Ray-Ban sunglasses. I got him some Ray-Ban sunglasses. You want him some Calvin Klein underwear. You want a Viori shorts because he loves the ones I always wear. I got him shorts and sunglasses. Yeah. Viori.
你们绝对会喜欢的。我送了他一副雷朋太阳镜。我送了他一副雷朋太阳镜。你想送他卡尔文·克莱因的内衣。你想送他Vouri的短裤，因为他特别喜欢我常穿的那款。我送了他短裤和太阳镜。对。Vouri。
You want him to wear shorts. I love this thing. He wanted the Godfather trilogy, 50th anniversary 4K. Oh my God. You got him VHS tapes, shorts and sunglasses. I would punch you in the face, then break up with you. They're not VHS. I called Sean the other day.
你想让他穿短裤。我太喜欢这个了。他想要《教父》三部曲的50周年4K纪念版。天哪。你送了他VHS录像带、短裤和太阳镜。我要是你的话，先呼你一巴掌，然后跟你分手。那不是VHS录像带。我前几天给肖恩打电话。
I called Sean the other night and they were having friends over and they were watching, they were watching Rogue One. Yep. You know why? Because you had a 13 year old over? Because they couldn't be more bored. Because they couldn't be more bored. Is that why?
我前几天晚上给肖恩打电话，他们当时正招待朋友，在看，在看《侠盗一号》。对。你知道为什么吗？因为你们家里有个13岁的小孩？因为他们不可能觉得更无聊了。因为他们不可能觉得更无聊了。是这样吗？
Is the answer because they couldn't be more fucking bored? Such a good movie. I love that movie. Okay. And then because we were getting ready to watch Andor, which is the prequel to Rogue One. How does one get ready? Is there like hamstring stretching? You watch the Rogue One.
难道是因为他们他妈的觉得再没有比这更无聊的了吗？多好的一部电影。我太喜欢那部电影了。好吧。然后因为我们正准备看《安多》，那是《侠盗一号》的前传。这怎么个准备法？难道还要拉伸一下腿筋吗？你看《侠盗一号》。
Andor. Oh yeah, I heard about that. I like to refer to no butt. Are you going to watch it? No, but that's because I'm a fucking grown up. I can't wait to watch it. I can't wait to steal that joke at your next boar fest. I can't wait for the fucking.
《安多》。哦，对，我听说过那个。我喜欢称之为“没屁股”。你要看吗？不看，那是因为我他妈是个成年人。我迫不及待想看了。我等不及要在你的下一场无聊派对上偷走这个笑话了。我等不及要他妈的……
Oh my God. It's so early. I feel like we're on tour again. I know. I feel it's terrible. And then we're eating and then we're just lazy. Oh God. Okay.
哦，天哪。时间太早了。我觉得我们又在巡演了。我懂。我觉得这太糟糕了。然后我们一直在吃，接着就变得懒洋洋的。哦，天哪。好吧。
Here we go. Just one eating. This fellow was not born in this country today. Oh, let's get to the guest. In college, he double majored in philosophy and computer science. And he comes from a family of doctors. What? Yep.
我们开始吧。就吃这一样。这家伙今天不是在这个国家出生的。哦，我们来请出今天的嘉宾吧。他在大学里主修哲学和计算机科学的双学位。而且他出身于一个医生世家。什么？对。
He really broke the pattern though when moving to the United States to pursue acting and comedy. One of his inspirations when breaking into comedy was Hugh Grant's performance in Four Weddings in a Funeral. Well, now he's inspiring me and the masses because he's a freaking comedy genius. Please welcome the brilliant Oscar-nominated Camille Nanjani. No way. Hey.
不过他搬到美国去追求表演和喜剧事业时，确实打破了这种常规。他刚开始涉足喜剧时，灵感来源之一就是休·格兰特在《四个婚礼和一个葬礼》中的表演。好吧，现在他正在激励着我和大众，因为他是一个绝顶的喜剧天才。让我们热烈欢迎才华横溢、获得过奥斯卡提名的库梅尔·南贾尼。不会吧。嘿。
Hey guys. Wow. Look at this fellow. This is Will's co-star. Wait a second. Wait a second. How's it going? Really good.
嘿，伙计们。哇。看看这家伙。这位是威尔的联合主演。等一下。等一下。最近怎么样？真的非常好。
Is this as exciting as you and McGregor? Camille. Wow. Only the beginning. This is so on brand for Camille now because he's going to put us in a tough spot. He came out with a question, which is what I love about him because he never rests. Wait. So have you guys, do you guys all know each other?
这有你和麦格雷戈在一起时那么让人激动吗？库梅尔。哇。这只是个开始。这太符合库梅尔的一贯作风了，因为他总是给我们出难题。他一上来就抛出了一个问题，这正是我喜欢他的地方，因为他从不消停。等等。所以你们，你们大家互相都认识吗？
Because Camille, we've never met. We've never met. Camille and I did, Camille very kindly did season one of Murderville and he was, I got to say this, you were brilliant. Very much so. Thank you. I had such a great time. What a great idea for a show.
因为库梅尔，我们从来没见过。我们从来没见过。库梅尔和我，库梅尔非常客气地参演了《默多尔维尔》的第一季，而且他——我得说，你演得太棒了。真的非常棒。谢谢。我度过了一段非常美好的时光。多棒的节目创意啊。
For those of it, for Tracy, if you haven't seen it, it's a scripted show except for the guest and me and Jason just experienced this because we were just on. The guest has no lines, no knowledge of anything that's going on. So they kind of have to go with Will who guides you through the episode. That's right. Based on an English show called Murder and Successville created by the brilliant Tom Davis. And we were lucky enough to come and bring and do our version here in Camille was in season one.
对于那些，对于特雷西，如果你没看过的话，这是一部有剧本的节目，除了嘉宾之外，我和杰森刚刚经历过，因为我们才刚上过。嘉宾没有任何台词，对正在发生的事情一无所知。所以他们基本上得跟着威尔走，由威尔引导你完成这一整集。没错。这是根据一部英国节目改编的，原名叫《成功镇谋杀案》，由才华横溢的汤姆·戴维斯创作。我们很幸运能把它引进过来，制作了我们自己的版本，库梅尔就参演了第一季。
How did you enjoy it? I had a great time. It was thrilling because you really, it's like, and you guys don't cheat at all. So in between takes, I'm in a separate room. Nobody's talking to me. Will, you didn't talk to me as well until we wrapped. So I really had like, you really sort of have no idea it's action. You walk into a scene.
你觉得感觉怎么样？我度过了一段非常棒的时光。这太刺激了，因为你真的，这就像是——而且你们是一点都不作弊啊。所以在拍摄间隙，我在一个单独的房间里。没有人跟我说话。威尔，直到我们杀青之前，你也没跟我说话。所以我是真的，你基本上完全不知道什么时候喊“开始”。你直接就走进了一个场景里。
It was thrilling because I didn't have to sort of prepare. And sometimes, you know, I get like nervous about that stuff, but it was great. And it was honestly, I was kind of trying to like paint you into a corner a bunch of times. Well, yeah, and you wouldn't have it. It was really impressive. You can't, you can't beat Terry Seattle. It was really tough.
这太刺激了，因为我根本不需要做什么准备。有时候，你知道的，我对那种事情会感到紧张，但这次感觉太棒了。老实说，我好几次都试图把你逼入绝境。好吧，是的，但你根本不买账。这真的让人印象深刻。你根本，你根本打败不了特里·西雅图。这太难了。
I really was like, there was one moment off camera where I was like, I got him. Fucking got this guy. And then it was the moment. What was the moment? I don't remember what it was exactly, but I remember being like, I was just riffing with you off camera and I said something and I was like, watch him wriggle out of this. And then I did. You got out infuriating.
我真的记得，有一次在镜头外，我心想：我抓住他了。我他妈的拿捏住这家伙了。然后就到了那个时刻。当时是什么时刻？我不记得具体是哪个时刻了，但我记得当时的情形是，我当时在镜头外跟你即兴互动，然后我随口说了句什么，心想：看他怎么摆脱这个困境。然后我就真的摆脱了。你脱身的样子太气人了。
Oh, is when is when you asked me to do an impression of you? No, that was on camera. And that was very funny. That was very good. But I got, but experiencing it on my own, I truly am not just saying this. There's no one more brilliant at improv and moving things along than Mr. Will Arnett. Oh, and Jason Bateman.
哦，是当你让我模仿你的时候吗？不，那是在镜头前。那个超级搞笑。那个非常精彩。但，我亲身体验过之后，我真的不是在说客套话。没有人比威尔·阿奈特先生在即兴表演和推动剧情方面更才华横溢了。哦，还有杰森·贝特曼。
Thank you, Sean. It's true. It's true. It's true. You know, you know, you know who Vince Vaughn is very, very good at. Yes. I will say that. Well, we don't need to get into other people.
谢谢你，肖恩。这是真的。这是真的。这是真的。你知道，你知道，你知道谁也非常，非常擅长这个吗？文斯·沃恩。对。我得这么说。好吧，我们没必要扯到别人身上。
I'm just saying, you know, Peter Sellers was good too. Hey, listen, but Kumail, so these guys, Sean and Jason. Those are the three greats of improv. Will Arnett, Peter Sellers and Vince Vaughn. Yeah. Fine. They'll mount Rushmore, if you will. Kumail, these guys came and did it just recently.
我只是说，你知道的，彼得·塞勒斯也很厉害。嘿，听着，库梅尔，这两个家伙，肖恩和杰森。这可是即兴表演的三大巨头。威尔·阿奈特、彼得·塞勒斯和文斯·沃恩。好吧。如果可以的话，他们就是拉什莫尔山上的雕像。库梅尔，这两个家伙最近刚来做过节目。
Sean and Jason did. We're doing big Christmas special, holiday special. Laugh Man. And we had a lot of fun. They got to see firsthand. Jason was sequestered for two days in a trailer with no Wi-Fi. Yeah. Or water or food.
肖恩和杰森来过。我们在做一个大型的圣诞特别节目，节日特别节目。《笑人》。我们玩得很开心。他们可是亲眼见识过了。杰森在没有Wi-Fi的拖车里被隔离了两天。对。或者没有水和食物。
Yeah. I thought that was excessive. I mean, you can take me to set in a blindfold. That's fun. Hey, look at this. Yeah. But keeping me in a hole without any food or water. I understand how that foments comedy or good feelings, good energy.
对。我觉得这有点过分了。我的意思是，你可以蒙着眼睛把我带到片场。那倒挺好玩的。嘿，你看这个。对。但把我关在一个没有水没有食物的小黑屋里。我真不懂这怎么能激发出喜剧效果，或者培养出好心情、好能量。
Wanted you to be hungry. You know, one needs just the basics. Sure. Well, listen, you made it through. I don't know how hashtag we're all, we're in this together and hashtag bless, but. I'm a question for you to did will talk to you as well. Or was he Terry, the two days until you wrapped. He was a little Terry.
他们希望你保持饥饿感。你知道的，人只需要最基础的东西就行了。当然。好吧，听着，你总算熬过来了。我不知道该说什么，加号“我们都在这条船上”，加号“感恩”，但是。我有个问题要问你，威尔也这样对你了吗？还是说这两天直到你杀青，他一直都是特里？他有点像特里。
He was a little will. He actually did a very, very good job at being, being the, being the boss over there, the, the, the producer and making sure everybody was okay and doing well. He was, that was, that was awesome. I could have been better. No, you could not have better. You, you never seen you work so hard and you've worked hard. Yeah, it's amazing.
他有点像威尔。他其实把那边的工作处理得非常非常出色，作为老板，作为制作人，确保每个人都状态良好、一切顺利。他表现得，那真的是太棒了。我本来可以表现得更好的。不，你不可能表现得更好了。你，你从来没见过谁工作这么拼命，而且你一直都很拼。对，这太惊人了。
That really was your set. It was a lot of fun. Well, I came out, I, I got to say one of the things that I really loved about having you on the show was, and that I realized about you is a, you're a really good guy. You're an easy guy to hang out with. You didn't assume that going in. I didn't know. You never know with people.
那真的完全是你的主场。这真的太有趣了。好吧，我得说，有一件事我非常喜欢你来我们节目做客，那就是我从你身上意识到的一点，a，你真的是个很好的人。跟你相处起来很轻松。我在去之前可没这种假设。我不知道。你永远摸不准别人是什么样。
Yeah. It was more, I didn't know you. I didn't know if you were going to be, you know, at Johnny big shot. You had a bunch of, you know, you're coming off a Silicon Valley Marvel. You're like super buff and I had to keep pointing out that I work out too. You did. Cause he's actually, it doesn't look like I do. Wait, but now that Marvel's over, do you just not give a shit and you eat anything you want?
对。更多的时候是我不了解你。我不知道你会不会，你知道的，摆出一副大牌的样子。你当时刚拍完《硅谷》和漫威的电影。你身材超级健美，而我不得不一直指出我也在锻炼。你确实说过。因为他实际上，看上去可不像我这样。等等，不过既然漫威已经结束了，你是不是就彻底放飞自我，想吃什么就吃什么了？
No. No, no, he's in crazy shit. Yeah. Your body's crazy. It's amazing. Oh, thank you. I did just do a thing that I gained like 25 pounds for. Like I had to be looked different and now I'm in the process.
不。不，不，他正在为疯狂的事情做准备。对。你的身材太疯狂了。这太惊人了。哦，谢谢。我最近确实接了个角色，为此我增肥了大约25磅。我必须看起来跟平时不一样，现在我正在……
Oh, Shippendales. Yeah. I'm in the process of losing it. Yeah. You had to, you had to put on fat to be in Shippendales. Yeah. The guy who founded Shippendales was, did not look like them. And part of the story is this guy's king of a world that he doesn't fit in, you know,
哦，脱衣舞男。对。我正在减脂的阶段。对。你为了演脱衣舞男还得增肥。对。当年创办“奇彭代尔”脱衣舞团的那个人，长得其实跟他们一点都不像。这个故事的一部分就是，这家伙成了一个他不属于的世界之王，你知道的，
cause it's all these like white dudes who look like Adonis and then this guy was like a bigger guy who did not look like a male stripper. So I had to, I had to change. You had to put on 25 pounds of belly. So how did you do, what was your, you could do it a bunch of different ways, eat a bunch of different stuff. What was your choice? Put your butter down. I, this is a way to do it healthy, you know, and then there's a way I did it, which is
因为那里全都是长得像阿多尼斯一样的白人帅哥，而这家伙是个块头比较大、看起来一点也不像男脱衣舞男的人。所以我必须改变。你不得不让肚子上增加25磅的肥肉。所以你是怎么做到的，你有很多不同的方法可以选，吃各种不同的东西。你选了什么？把你的黄油放下。你知道，有一种是健康的增肥方法，然后还有我用的那种方法，就是
I just ate pies and fries and fried chicken. Yeah, Sean, they keep, they keep moving the start date on whatever you're gaining weight for you. Cause gaining weight for is called anoscopy. Sean, you look fucking great. By the way, I've only had general anesthesia once. I was a kid. I had an ear operation and I made the exact same joke going in. Don't touch my ass.
我只是狂吃馅饼、薯条和炸鸡。对，肖恩，他们一直在推迟你为了增肥而准备的那个节目的开机时间。因为你增肥是为了做肠镜。肖恩，你看起来帅呆了。顺便说一句，我只做过一次全身麻醉。我还是个孩子的时候。我做过一次耳朵手术，当时进去的时候我也开了个一模一样的玩笑。别碰我的屁股。
I was eight years old. Right. That's right. Very inappropriate. Sean, eight year olds are making your joke. And it was an ear surgery. Oh no. Wait, come out.
我当时八岁。没错。太不合适了。肖恩，八岁的小孩都在用你的梗。而且那还是一场耳朵手术。哦，不。等等，库梅尔。
How hard is it taking off the, the pies and milkshakes? Me? The hardest part is readjusting to having to eat healthy. Like, you know, honestly, when I start, cause I was eating so unhealthy, I was eating four huge meals every day. So losing the first, like 10 was pretty easy, just going back to normal. The hard thing is not having that expectation of every day I can eat whatever I want. That's very tricky.
把那些馅饼和奶昔带来的脂肪减掉有多难？我吗？最难的部分是重新适应必须吃健康的食物。就像，说实话，当我开始减肥的时候，因为我之前吃得太不健康了，我每天吃四顿超级大餐。所以前10磅减下来其实挺容易的，只要恢复正常饮食就行了。难点在于不能再抱有“我每天想吃什么就能吃什么”的这种期待了。这真的很棘手。
It's hard to like rewire to that cause your, your taste palate changes, you know, like I, there was a time when I was like, you know, eating a certain way. I was like, fruit is so good. I remember I would bite into a pear and go. This is like the greatest dessert in the world. And then after gaining the weight, I was like, pear suck compared to like cheesecake. So bland. Yeah.
要重新调整这种心态很难，因为你的味蕾已经改变了，你知道的，比如曾经有一段时间，我以某种特定的方式饮食。当时我想，水果太好吃了。我记得我咬了一口梨，然后感叹道：这简直是世界上最棒的甜点。然后在增肥之后，我觉得：跟芝士蛋糕比起来，梨简直弱爆了。太清淡了。对。
I just say, let yourself eat whatever you want. That's right. But Sean, you just put sriracha on anything, right? And then down it goes. Yep. One way, one way. So wait, listen, Camille, I, my friend Chuck Sekula is in your show. Shout out.
我只想说，让自己随心所欲地吃吧。没错。不过肖恩，你不管吃什么都会倒上是拉差辣酱，对吧？然后一口闷。对。没错，没错。所以等等，听着，库梅尔，我的朋友查克·塞库拉在你的剧里。打个招呼。
And as a Chippendale, yeah, I've known him since I was 18 years old. And I texted him last night if he has any stories with you. And his text back to me was in the first two episodes, he said he, you might remember him at the hot dog vendor they find on Venice Beach. And then I said, do you have any good stories with you? And Camille goes, no good stories. No, I have no. He was the hot dog vendor who becomes the dancer.
他演一个脱衣舞男，对，我从18岁起就认识他了。我昨晚给他发短信，问他有没有关于你的故事。他回给我的短信说，在前两集里，他说你可能还记得他，就是那个在威尼斯海滩找到的热狗小贩。然后我问他：“你跟他有什么好故事吗？”库梅尔就说：“没有好故事。没有，我没有。”他就是那个后来变成舞者的热狗小贩。
Yes. He was great. Okay. Thanks. That's it. He was awesome. He wore a crazy mullet for the show. He did.
对。他演得太棒了。好的。谢谢。就这样。他太棒了。他在剧里留了一个疯狂鲻鱼头。他确实留了。
Can't wait to see it. But wait, the trailer looks great. I love it. It looks really good. From hot dog vendor to Chippendale's dancer, there's sort of a correlation there. Oh, go ahead. Go ahead. I don't know.
等不及要看了。不过等等，预告片看起来太棒了。我很喜欢。看起来真的很不错。从热狗小贩到脱衣舞男，这之间某种程度上确实有点联系。哦，请继续。请继续。我不知道。
I'm just, I don't have it yet, but I'm in a montage right now where, and I'm in Camille's sort of perspective and we're blending hot dogs and dancing and he starts to get this idea, this big homoerotic light bulb goes off in his head. Because he's holding a hot dog. Yeah. Right. Yeah. I actually see somebody holding a hot dog down by their waist and I'm like, wait.
我只是，我还没看到那部分，但我现在正处于一个蒙太奇片段中，在这个片段里，我身处库梅尔的视角中，我们把热狗和舞蹈融合在一起，他的脑海里突然闪现出这样一个灵感，一个巨大的充满男同性恋色彩的灵光一现。因为他手里拿着一个热狗。对。没错。对。我其实看到有人把热狗拿在腰部的位置，然后我就想：等等。
Sure. Just dancing. Oh, there it is. You want sauerkraut? What is happening? We'll be right back. Hey, smart list listener. We get support from FanDuel.
当然。只是跳舞。哦，原来在这儿。你要酸菜吗？这到底是怎么回事？我们马上回来。嘿，智能清单的听众们。我们得到了FanDuel的大力支持。
Football season is underway in the thick of it. We're in the thick of it. So now is the perfect time to download FanDuel, America's number one sports book. Because right now new customers get a no sweat first bet up to $1,000. That's free bets back if your first bet doesn't win. Just sign up with promo code smart list. Because listen, I'm going to talk about the things you're going to like about FanDuel. FanDuel has all your favorite bets from the money line to point spreads to player props.
足球赛季正如火如荼地进行着，我们正身处其中。我们正处在赛季的白热化阶段。所以现在是下载FanDuel的绝佳时机，这可是全美排名第一的体育博彩公司。因为现在新用户可以享受高达1000美元的无风险首注优惠。如果你的第一笔投注没有赢，退还你免费投注的金额。只需使用促销代码 smart list 注册即可。因为听听看，我要跟你聊聊你会喜欢FanDuel的哪些地方。FanDuel拥有你所有最喜欢的盘口，从独赢盘到让分盘，再到球员道具盘。
You can combine your bets for a chance at a bigger payout with the same game parlay. With live betting, you'll get updated odds on games that have already started. The app is safe, secure, and super easy to use. Get your winnings paid fast. I'm ripping off my shirt. So sign up today with promo code smart list for your no sweat first bet. Make every moment more this season with FanDuel official sports book partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusions apply.
你可以将你的下注组合起来，通过同场比赛过关投注来获得赢取更高奖金的机会。通过实时投注，你将获得已经开始的比赛的最新赔率。这款应用程序安全、可靠且超级容易使用。让你赢得的奖金快速到账。我已经把我的衬衫撕开了。所以今天就使用促销代码 smart list 注册，享受你的无风险首注吧。在这个赛季，用FanDuel——NFL官方体育博彩合作伙伴，让每一个时刻都更加精彩。21岁以上，适用相关限制条件。
C show notes for full disclaimer. Smart list is sponsored by better help. So I don't know if anybody knows me really well and you guys are getting to know me a little better is I'm kind of like a, I have one of those caretaker personalities. And a lot of times those personalities, you kind of put yourself last. And so it's something I'm working on through therapy. And fortunately, you know, therapists are trained to help you figure out the cause of challenging emotions and learn productive coping skills, which makes therapy the closest thing to a guided tour of the complex engine called you.
完整免责声明请参阅节目说明。智能清单由BetterHelp赞助播出。所以，我不知道是否有人真的很了解我，而你们现在也开始更了解我一点了，那就是我有点像那种，我有那种照顾型人格。很多时候，拥有这种人格的人，你总是会把自己的需求放在最后。所以这是我一直在通过心理治疗来解决的问题。幸运的是，你知道的，治疗师受过专业训练，可以帮助你找出引发具有挑战性的情绪的原因，并学习富有成效的应对技巧，这使得心理治疗最接近于对名为“你”的复杂引擎的导游之旅。
So for me, I have to learn how to kind of put myself first and and just perfect example. Jason just texted me. And and I stopped talking to answer him because I wanted him to feel good that I was there for him. But I need to focus on this and being there for you guys. So it's something I'm working on and something I think a lot of people struggle with is the anxiety that goes with being a caretaker and or having a caretaking personality or as it's commonly known, it's like a people pleaser. So those are my issues. What are yours?
所以对我来说，我必须学会如何把自我放在首位，这有一个完美的例子。杰森刚刚给我发了短信。然后我停下说话去回复他，因为我想让他觉得我一直都在支持他，从而让他感觉好受一些。但我需要专注于此，专注于支持你们。所以这是我正在努力解决的问题，也是我认为许多人都在挣扎的事情——那就是伴随着照顾他人和/或拥有照顾型人格而产生的焦虑，或者俗称的“讨好型人格”。所以这些是我的问题。你们的是什么？
Don't tell me now use better help. As the world's largest therapy service, better help has matched 3 million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online. Plus it's affordable. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to match with a therapist. If things aren't clicking, you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime. It couldn't be simpler. No waiting rooms, no traffic, no endless searching for the right therapist.
现在别告诉我，去用BetterHelp吧。作为全球最大的心理治疗服务机构，BetterHelp已经为300万人匹配了拥有专业执照并经过背景调查的治疗师，100%在线提供服务。另外它价格实惠。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与治疗师进行匹配。如果感觉不对盘，你可以随时轻松更换新治疗师。再简单不过了。没有候诊室，没有交通拥堵，无需无休止地寻找合适的治疗师。
Learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com. That's better help H-E-L-P dot com slash smart list. Smart list listeners. This episode is brought to you by Zell. When anyone sends you money or if you need to get paid back, always ask for Zell. With Zell, the money goes straight into your bank account. You don't have to download another app because it's probably already in your banking app. It's in over 1600 different banking apps and it works even if the center bank somewhere different than you in the United States.
访问 betterhelp.com 了解更多信息并节省首月10%的费用。网址是 betterhelp.com 斜杠 smart list。智能清单的听众们。本期节目由Zell赞助播出。当任何人给你转账，或者你需要别人还钱时，一定要用Zell。通过Zell，钱会直接存入你的银行账户。你不需要下载另一个应用程序，因为它可能已经内置在你的手机银行应用中了。它已被集成到1600多家不同的银行应用中，而且即使付款人的银行与你在美国的不同，它也照样管用。
Jason, Will and I use Zell to pay each other back all the time. Jason and I have both visited Will's summer home on the East Coast and we paid him back for meals and other stuff with Zell. We have also used Zell for things like splitting the bill for group dinners as well as paying each other back for gifts we brought together for like a mutual friend or coworkers or whatever. And so when we need to get paid back, we always ask each other for Zell. Look for Zell and your banking app today. All right, back to the show. Okay, so Camel, we don't know each other.
杰森、我和威尔经常用Zell互相转账。杰森和我都去过威尔在东海岸的避暑别墅，我们用Zell把饭钱和其他杂物的钱还给了他。我们还用Zell处理过诸如平摊团队聚餐的账单，以及互相还钱垫付的礼物费用——比如我们一起送给共同的朋友或同事的礼物之类的事情。所以当我们需要别人还钱时，我们总是要求对方用Zell。今天就在你的银行应用中寻找Zell吧。好了，回到节目中。好的，所以库梅尔，我们还互相不认识。
I'd like to start at the beginning like we often do on this. Pakistan, what was it like growing up there? What made you move to the United States and give us all that stuff because I don't know those answers. And what was the name of your high school girlfriend? Keep going. That's a callback to Murderville with Sean. You have not watched. I will watch your episode. It was, you know, it's hard to say because it's just what my life was.
我想像我们在这档节目中经常做的那样，从头开始聊起。巴基斯坦，在那里长大是什么感觉？是什么促使你搬到美国来的？把这些都跟我们讲讲吧，因为我还不知道这些答案。还有你高中女朋友叫什么名字？继续。这是在致敬肖恩在《默多尔维尔》里的表现。你根本没看过。我会去看你那一集的。这，你知道的，这很难说，因为这就是我当时的生活。
So it was the same as kind of here, I guess. Yeah, but my thing is like there's a million cultural differences between Pakistan culture and American culture. What were some of that that you're thankful for and what are some that you really miss that, you know, I mean, the way when I you're thankful for for the move. Wow, what do I mean? I missed the food, you know, I mean, our food is the best food in the world. I was just what's your favorite, favorite, favorite Pakistani food? Yes, biryani. It's like biryani. What is that? What is that?
所以我想，这跟我现在的生活差不多吧。是的，但我的意思是，巴基斯坦文化和美国文化之间存在着数百万个文化差异。有哪些是你心存感激的，又有哪些是你真心怀念的，你知道的，我的意思是，当你——你对这次搬迁心存感激。哇，我的意思是？我想念那里的食物，你知道的，我的意思是，我们的食物是世界上最好吃的。我当时就想，你最最最喜欢的巴基斯坦食物是什么？对，比尔亚尼抓饭。就像比尔亚尼。那是什么？那是什么？
What goes on? There's rice, there's meat, there's some meat in there. And what you do is, and that's the way my mom makes it, which is because of where she's from. She's from a town in India called Calcutta. You put potatoes in there too. But the whole thing with biryani is how slow can you cook it? You know, that's like the, oh, I cooked this for six hours, seven hours, eight hours. That's the thing of it. And you know, my grandmother's biryani was the best biryani I'd ever had. And my mom's was like the second best. It was like 5% worse, but it was so close. Yeah.
里面有什么？有米饭，有肉，里面有一些肉。你的做法是——这也是我妈妈的做法，因为她来自那个地方。她来自印度的一个小镇叫加尔各答。你还在里面放土豆。但比尔亚尼的精髓在于你能把它慢炖多久。你知道的，那种感觉就是：“哦，我炖了六个小时、七个小时、八个小时。”这就是它的魅力所在。你知道的，我奶奶做的比尔亚尼是我吃过最好吃的。而我妈妈做的是第二好吃的。大概差了百分之五，但已经非常接近了。对。
And my grandmother passed away a few years ago and this time I was with my parents and I ate my mom's and it was like only 3% worse. She's like, she's getting there. Do you, do you great? Do you let her know? Do you go like, hey, you're getting better? I did. Oh my God, you're a tough customer. No, that's compliment. I think it meant a lot to her because she started crying. I don't know if it was good crying or bad crying. But Camel, what don't you miss?
我奶奶几年前去世了，这次我和我父母在一起，我吃了我妈妈做的，感觉只差了百分之三。我妈心想：她正在进步。你会，你会夸她吗？你会不会说：“嘿，你手艺见长啊？”我说了。哦，天哪，你可真是个难伺候的顾客。不，那是赞美。我想这对她意义重大，因为她当时都哭了。我不知道那是喜极而泣还是伤心落泪。不过库梅尔，你最不怀念什么？
Sean could walk you through some of the nice rice dishes at Chin Chin. Maybe you can find a nice little replacement. By the way, you just order, you order a side of rice with all of the options. And there you go. Rice is my favorite thing. That was the hardest thing to give up. What don't, what don't you miss about accent? This question is a trap and I'm not falling. It's a trap.
肖恩可以带你参观一下鼎泰丰那些美味的米饭。也许你能找到一个不错的替代品。顺便说一句，你点所有菜的时候都可以单点一份米饭。这不就结了。米饭是我最喜欢的东西。那是我最难割舍的东西。你对家乡有什么不怀念的？ accent？这个问题是个陷阱，我才不会上当呢。这是个陷阱。
Okay, fine. No, I just didn't know if it was like a. Everything's a trap. What moves you guys to the next stage? I'm fine. This is a dick fest. Kind of like speaking a hot talk. I'd like my show.
好吧，好吧。不，我只是不知道这算不算是个。万事皆陷阱。是什么促使你们进入下一个阶段的？我很好。这简直是个纯爷们儿派对。有点像在说热狗。我挺喜欢我的节目的。
Welcome to Chippendales. Transition to Chippendales. Here we go. Dick fest. Tell us your favorite part of Chippendales. Favorite part? I mean, I think it's a really, really great show. I genuinely do.
欢迎来到《欢迎来到切彭代尔》。过渡到《欢迎来到切彭代尔》。我们开始吧。纯爷们儿派对。快告诉我们你最喜欢《欢迎来到切彭代尔》的哪个部分。最喜欢的部分？我的意思是，我觉得这是一部非常非常棒的剧。我发自内心地这么认为。
I think my favorite part is working with the other actors. They were so, do you guys see white lotus? Yes. Murray Bartlett. I hear. Oh my God. It's one of the best shows I've ever seen. It's so good.
我觉得我最喜欢的部分是与其他演员合作。他们真的——你们看过《白莲花》吗？看过。莫瑞·巴特利特。我听说。哦，天哪。这是我看过最好的剧之一。太棒了。
And Murray's in our show and he's fantastic. I got to work with Julia Lewis, you know, I've been a fan of forever. She's amazing. Annaly Ashford, who's like a Broadway legend. She's one of Tony's. So did you have to do any dancing? I didn't, which was good because I can't do it.
而且莫瑞也参演了我们的剧，他表现得太棒了。我有幸能和茱莉亚·路易斯合作，你知道的，我一直是她的超级粉丝。她太惊艳了。还有安娜丽·阿什福德，她简直是百老汇的传奇人物。她拿过托尼奖。所以你得在剧里跳舞吗？我没有，这挺好的，因为我不会跳舞。
No, not much of a dancer. Would you, would you have, but you did, you did an Eternals. I tried an Eternals. Let's say you, let's say you, let's say they wanted you to play the lead in the Chip and Dale thing, which means you had to do a lot, a lot of dance,
不，我不太擅长跳舞。你会，你会不会——但你在《永恒族》里跳过。我在《永恒族》里尝试过。假设你，假设你——假设他们想让你在切彭代尔的那个项目里演主角，这意味着你必须做大量的舞蹈，
a lot of pole work. Would you have, would you have said yes? Well, I want to clarify, I did play the lead, but I didn't have to. The lead dancer, sorry. Okay, cool it. Camille, all right. Jesus.
大量的钢管舞动作。你当时会，你会答应吗？好吧，我想澄清一下，我确实演了主角，但我不需要……抱歉，是领舞。好吧，冷静点。库梅尔，行了。天哪。
Can I get back to, I just want to know what made your family move from Pakistan and the United States. And then we're going to double back to the pole dancing. Go ahead. It was actually love of pole dancing that made my family move. They were like, we should know where that happens.
我能回到刚才的话题吗？我只是想知道是什么让你的家人从巴基斯坦搬到了美国。然后我们再绕回钢管舞的话题。请继续。其实是出于对钢管舞的热爱才促使我家人搬家的。他们当时想：我们应该去那个钢管舞盛行的地方看看。
No, I moved on my own for college. My family didn't move until many, many years later. So I just moved on my own. I went to Grinnell College in Iowa because I honestly didn't know that, I didn't understand how big America was and I only knew America from movies and TV shows. And I, I was not very represented.
不，我是为了上大学自己搬过去的。我家人直到很多很多年以后才搬过去。所以我只是自己搬过去的。我去了爱荷华州的格林内尔学院，因为老实说我并不知道——我不明白美国到底有多大，我对美国的了解仅限于电影和电视节目。而且，我在其中并没有得到很好的代表。
So I was very surprised. I thought it was all New York and LA. And then suddenly, you know, I'm with pigs and corn. So it was just a, just a desire to change scenery. Well, I think the plan was always for my family to move out of Pakistan and come to America. That was always the plan. So the school they sent me to was one where the most of the,
所以我当时非常惊讶。我以为全美国只有纽约和洛杉矶。然后突然之间，你知道的，我周围全都是猪和玉米。所以这纯粹是一种改变环境的渴望。好吧，我想我家里人一直的计划就是离开巴基斯坦去美国。这一直是他们的计划。所以他们送我去的那所学校，大部分的，
you know, education was in English. And that the plan was to always try and move to America. If possible. And did you are, did you, were you taught English before you left Pakistan? Yes. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I grew up, you know, I learned English in school,
你知道的，教育都是用英语进行的。他们的计划一直是尽可能尝试搬到美国去。如果可能的话。那你，你在离开巴基斯坦之前有人教过你英语吗？是的。对。对。我的意思是，我是在学校里长大，你知道的，我在学校里学过英语，
but I also learned, I grew up watching so many movies and TV shows. Well, I thought that was funny that Hugh Grant was your inspiration. Not that he's not talented and funny and all those great things. Yeah. But who else?
但我也通过看大量的电影和电视节目来学习。好吧，我觉得休·格兰特是你的灵感来源这挺有意思的。并不是说他不才华横溢、幽默风趣以及具备所有这些优秀的品质。对。但还有谁？
Well, you know, Bill Murray, obviously, like Ghostbusters was my favorite, favorite thing. Yeah. Are you afraid of no ghost? I am afraid of ghost. Oh, okay. Yeah. Which is why it was an aspirational love of Bill Murray
嗯，你知道的，比尔·默里，很显然，比如《捉鬼敢死队》是我最最喜欢的东西。对。你怕不怕鬼？我怕鬼。哦，好吧。所以说，我对比尔·默里的崇拜其实是因为他“什么鬼都不怕”的这种特质。我真的，对。但我记得在学校里，大概是幼儿园或者一年级的时候。我记得当我刚开始识字、学习英语的时候，我感到非常沮丧，心想：这些东西我明明都已经会说了，为什么我非得用另一种完全不同的方式去说“老虎”呢？
for being afraid of no ghosts. I really, yeah. But I remember in school, I think it was kindergarten or first grade. I remember when I first started reading, learning English and being like very upset that I'm like, I already know how to say all this stuff. Why do I need a whole other way of saying tiger?
你知道的，这些我本来就知道。所以我记得我第一次开始学英语的时候就是这种感觉。所以你其实通过看电视学到了很多英语？我觉得我通过看电视和电影，学会了非常流利的英语对话。哇。而且全都是你们看的那种电影，比如《星球大战》和《印第安纳琼斯》
You know, I already know this. So I remember the first time I started learning English. So you learned a lot of English from just watching television. I think I learned to be like very conversant in English watching television and movies. Wow. And it was all the movies you guys watched, like, you know, Star Wars and Indiana Jones
以及所有那些东西。对。但我想探讨的是，库梅尔，如果我们能直接跳过的话——因为你来到这里，在这里上大学，快进几年后，你做了很多工作，然后你和你的妻子写了这部电影。埃米莉·戈登，太棒了。
and all that stuff. Yeah. But you, but what I want to get into, Camille, if we can just jump, because so you come here, you go to college here, fast forward a few years later, you work a bunch, and then you and your wife write this film. Emily Gordon, amazing.
埃米莉·戈登，你们一起写了这部电影。对。《大病》，由我的老朋友迈克尔·肖阿尔特执导，我认识他很多很多年了。跟我们聊聊这个创作过程，它是怎么构思出来的，是怎么变成现实的，以及这部电影，你知道的，是多么的惊艳。
Emily Gordon, write this film together. Yes. The Big Sick, directed by my old friend, Michael Showalter, whom I've known for years and years and years. Talk us through that process, how it came about, how it came to be, and how the film, you know, was brilliant.
而且你们，你知道的，显然还获得了奥斯卡提名之类的。还有阿帕图，贾德，你是怎么加入进来的？贾德，对。我们没得奖。我们获得了提名。抱歉，抱歉，是提名。没得奖，老实说也没法沮丧，
And you guys, you know, obviously winning Oscars and all that. And Apatow, Judd, how did you get involved with that? Judd, yeah. We didn't win. We got nominated. Sorry, sorry, nominated. Get out one and honestly cannot be upset
因为《逃出绝命镇》是一部非常棒的电影。对，所以这一切是怎么发生的？这一切的起源是什么？我基本上是，我在贾德监制的由杰森·席格尔和埃米莉·布朗特主演的《五年之约》里客串了一个转瞬即逝、眨眼就会错过的极小角色，就只有一个场景。然后我在奥斯汀的西南偏南电影节上。
because Get Out is a fantastic movie. Yeah, so how did it all come about? What's the genesis of all of it? So I basically was, I'd sort of done a very, very small blink and you miss it part in five-year engagement with Jason Siegel and Emily Blunt that Judd produced, just one scene. And then I was at South by Southwest Festival in Austin.
我以前经常去那里表演单口喜剧。我上了皮特·霍姆斯过去主持的一档脱口秀节目，贾德是嘉宾之一。而我也是嘉宾之一。然后贾德说：“嘿，你就是那个在我的电影里只有一句台词的家伙。”我说：“对，我是你的超级粉丝。很高兴认识你。”
I used to go do stand-up comedy there all the time. And I did this talk show that Pete Holmes used to host and Judd was one of the guests. And I was one of the guests. And Judd was like, hey, you're that guy who was one line in my movie. And I was like, yeah, I'm such a big fan. Nice to meet you.
他非常友善。他非常称赞我，因为我当时还没看过那部电影。他说：“你演得太棒了。而且你刚好在我们最需要的时候逗笑全场。”等我看了电影之后，我心想：他当时只是在说客套话，因为那个角色真的什么都不是。他是个好人。他是个好人。
He was very nice. He was very complimentary because I hadn't seen the movie yet. He's like, you're so great. And you really get a big laugh exactly when we need it. And when I watched the movie, I was like, he was just being nice because it's truly a nothing part. He's a nice fella. He's a nice fella.
我们一起上了这档脱口秀，那个周末我们一起闲逛，度过了一段非常美好的时光。然后当我那一周回到家时，我的经纪人打电话来说：“嘿，贾德·阿帕图打来电话了。他想见你。他想知道你有没有什么拍电影的想法。”于是我写下了大概五个点子，全都是那种，你知道的，很蠢的点子。
But we did this talk show together and we sort of hung out that weekend and had a great time. And then when I got home that week, my manager called and was like, hey, Judd Apatow called. And he wants to meet you. And he wants to know if you have any like movie ideas. And so I sort of wrote down like five ideas, all like kind of, you know, dumb ideas.
我去找他，跟他说：其中一个点子其实是关于一个鬼魂的，这个鬼魂同时也是一个愿望，就像一个愿望死去了，然后它变成了一个鬼魂。他听了之后说：“这些点子都很有趣。”然后我说：“然后，你知道的，我女朋友在我们刚开始约会的时候昏迷了两个星期，对吧？而我一直在医院陪着她的家人。”
And I went and pitched them to him like this. One really was about a ghost which it's a ghost which is also a wish, like a wish dies. And then it's a ghost and he's like, these are all really fun. And then I was like, and then, you know, my girlfriend was in a coma for two weeks, right? When we first started dating and I hung out with her family the whole time.
他当时就说：“就是这个。”你们是在她昏迷的时候开始约会的吗？我们就是那个时候开始的。对。她真是一个很好的倾听者。不，但说真的，抛开笑话不谈，等等，她是在你们刚开始约会后不久就陷入昏迷的吗？
And he was like, yes. Did you guys start dating when she was in a coma? That's when we started. Yeah. She's such a good listener. No, but seriously, I mean, all jokes aside, wait, she went into a coma within, when you first started dating?
几个月后。哇。对。这太疯狂了。是的，这确实疯狂。跟我们简单聊聊那段经历吧，在你能接受的范围内。我们约会了几个月。
A few months. Wow. Yeah. That's crazy. Yeah, it is crazy. Talk us through that a little bit, as much as you're comfortable with. We were dating a few months.
我遇到了这个女孩，你知道的，我当时想：哇，她真的是太棒了。我想我们大概约会了六七个月，但真的只是在约会。我们没有同居。对。我不觉得，我不知道，我觉得我们当时好像还没有对彼此说过“我爱你”之类的话。
I met her, I met this girl and, you know, I was like, wow, she's really, really awesome. And I think we were dating about six or seven months, but it really was just dating. We weren't living together. Right. I don't think, I don't know if, I don't think we'd said I love you or anything yet.
我遇到了她，我遇到了这个女孩，然后，你知道的，我就觉得，哇，她真的很棒。我想我们大概约会了六七个月，但真的只是约会。我们没有同居。对。我不觉得，我不知道是否，我想我们当时还没有说过我爱你或类似的话。
And then suddenly one day, she was, she hadn't been feeling well for a couple of weeks. I don't know how much detail anyway. No. I was at a show and I couldn't get in touch with her. And I remember like, I was just calling and calling and calling and, because she was going to go to the doctor in the afternoon and I just couldn't get in touch with her and had a terrible set.
然后突然有一天，她就，她已经感觉身体不舒服好几周了。我不知道具体细节怎么样。不。我在看演出，我联系不上她。我记得我一直在疯狂地打电话、打电话、打电话，因为她下午要去看医生，而我就是联系不上她，那场演出糟透了。
And at 11 p.m. Yeah. Sorry about that. Sorry about that. Sorry about that. You know, it didn't really, didn't really get a lot. There's also something kind of, anyway, I'll tell you about that in a second.
然后在晚上11点。对。真对不起。真对不起。真对不起。你知道，其实也没什么，其实没得到多少。还有一种情况，总之，我一会儿跟你说。
And then at 11, she called and she was like, hey, I'm in the hospital. And so, and she told me where she was and I ran over. You tell her about the set? Yeah. I mean, I opened with the set. I'd love to come, but I'm pretty banged up about this. Yeah. I got to go do some rewriting.
然后到了11点，她打电话来说，嘿，我在医院。然后，她告诉我她在哪里，我就跑过去了。你跟她讲了演出的事吗？对。我的意思是，我是伴着那个演出开场的。我很想去，但我因为这事受了不小的打击。对。我得去改改稿子。
I'm going to go sign up for another open mic. I got to wash this taste out. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm sorry. This really is an emergency. I need a good set.
我要去报名另一个开放麦。我得把这个糟糕的印象洗掉。对。对。对。我很抱歉。这真的是个紧急情况。我需要一场精彩的演出。
How many emergencies? I mean, that is how I opened. I was like, honey, I'm trying to get in touch with you. I had a bad set and I really need to vent. Yeah. Good for you. But there's a scene in the movie where I sort of walk through the hospital and I find Zoe Kazan who plays Emily in the movie.
有多少紧急情况？我是说，我当时就是这么开场的。我说，亲爱的，我一直在联系你。我有一场糟糕的演出，我真的需要发泄一下。对。真有你的。但电影里有一个场景，我差不多是穿过医院，找到了在电影里饰演艾米丽的佐伊·卡赞。
And it's very similar. You know, you sort of feel like you're going into this weird world. And I saw her sitting in her hospital bed and she just looks so different than she did this morning. You know, she was like hooked up to all this kind of stuff. And then she, the doctor came, the nurse came and I was like, can we go home? And she said, no, we have to wait until the doctor comes in at 6am. So they gave her a room.
非常相似。你知道，你那种感觉就像是走进了一个诡异的世界。我看到她坐在病床上，她看起来和今天早上完全不同。你知道，她身上插满了各种各样的管子。然后她，医生来了，护士来了，我说，我们能回家吗？她说，不行，我们得等到早上6点医生来查房。于是他们给她安排了一间病房。
The doctor came in at 6am, saw her, he came out and he was like, hey, so we need to intubate her right now. This is all in the movie, but it's really true. They were like, we need to intubate her. And I was like, what does that mean? And they're like, well, you know, we have to put her on a machine, things in her neck and we're going to put her in a medically induced coma. And I was like, what?
医生早上6点来查房，看了看她，他走出来说，嘿，我们需要马上给她插管。这些都在电影里，但都是真的。他们说，我们需要给她插管。我说，那是什么意思？他们说，嗯，你知道的，我们得给她用上机器，把东西插进她的脖子里，我们要让她进入药物诱导的昏迷状态。我说，什么？
They're like, we have to do it. So we need somebody to sign this. And I was like, they were like, are you her husband? And I was like, no, and people don't believe this part of the story. It's completely true. He's like, we, she needs to go into this thing. We need a family member to sign this. So you need to just like lie to us and just sign it because this needs to happen.
他们说，我们必须这么做。所以我们需要有人签这个字。我说，他们问，你是她丈夫吗？我说，不是，人们都不相信故事的这一部分。这完全是真的。他说，我们，她需要做这个。我们需要一个家属来签这个字。所以你只需要对我们撒个谎，把字签了就行，因为这必须要发生。
Wow. And I remember I signed it and they ran into a room. It was her and like three or four other guys. And I just watched them do it. Like I watched them do, they should not have, they should have been like, hey, sir, take a walk, go to the vending machine or something. But I watched, I watched them do it. What the hell?
哇。我记得我签了字，然后他们跑进了一个房间。里面有她和另外三四个家伙。我就看着他们做。就像我看着他们做，他们本不该这样的，他们本该说，嘿，先生，去走走吧，去买卖部或者干点别的。但我看着，我看着他们做。搞什么鬼？
What was she suffering from Kerry? Are you allowed to say? Yeah. So she, I don't want to talk about her diagnosis too much because that's her story. She talks about it, but she eventually got diagnosed with something called adult onset stills disease, which is sort of like arthritis, but for the organs. And so it attacks your lungs, kidneys, heart, you know, it got any treatment for it. Yes.
她得的是什么病，库迈尔？你能说吗？可以。所以她，我不想过多谈论她的诊断，因为那是她的故事。她自己会说，但她最终被诊断出患有一种叫做成人发病型斯蒂尔病的东西，这有点像关节炎，但是针对器官的。它会攻击你的肺、肾脏、心脏，你知道的，你接受过治疗吗？是的。
And then later, so this treatment at the time was steroids. They just pumper full of steroids. It's episodic. So it's something that comes on, you know, she's lucky. She only feels it about once a year. But once you know what it is, you take the pill and that's good. It is. And then 10 years later, she got diagnosed with another thing called CVID,
后来，当时的治疗方法是类固醇。他们给她注射了大量类固醇。这是发作性的。所以这是一种会发作的病，你知道的，她很幸运。她大约一年才发作一次左右。但一旦你知道那是什么，你吃片药就好了。确实如此。然后10年後，她被诊断出患有另一种叫做CVID的病，
which is common variable immunodeficiency. And that there is a new treatment for and she goes and gets this treatment every month. Her basically a body does not make antibodies at all. Like the normal level is like 1200 and her level was literally one, like it was one. And so she basically has to go get this infusion every month and now she's, you know, she's doing really well. She's great. You want to know what a small world it is.
也就是常见变异型免疫缺陷。这种病现在有了新疗法，她每个月都会去接受这种治疗。她基本上身体完全不产生抗体。正常的水平大约是1200，而她的水平字面意思是1，就像是1。所以她基本上每个月都得去输液，现在她，你知道的，她状态非常好。她棒极了。你想知道世界有多小吗。
You are a spokesperson for up the antibodies. That's right. Right. And my niece is the senior project manager of that campaign. Oh, really? Isn't that crazy? You know, Sean last week, he went to have his colonoscopy and when he kept the doctor looked at her and he said that he's got what he described as an antibody.
你是“提高抗体”活动的代言人。没错。对。我侄女是该活动的高级项目经理。哦，真的吗？这不是太疯狂了吗？你知道，肖恩上周去做肠镜检查时，医生看了看她，说他得了他所描述的一种抗体。
Yeah. Yeah. Not quite formed fully. So wait, so listen, I heard, I heard, and then you guys turned this whole thing into this great movie and I heard the movie ended up on porn hub. Is that, is that true? The entire movie? Yeah.
对。对。没有完全发育好。等等，所以听着，我听说，我听说，然后你们把整件事拍成了一部很棒的电影，我听说这部电影最后上了Pornhub。是，是真的吗？整部电影？对。
I think they do that sometimes, you know, like certain movies just end up on porn hub. We were on porn hub for a second. That's crazy. The whole movie? Yeah. It got pirated. I'll say. I don't know how many views it got.
我想他们有时会那样做，你知道的，就像某些电影最后会莫名其妙上了Pornhub。我们有那么一小会儿在Pornhub上。太疯狂了。整部电影？对。被盗版了。我只能说。我不知道它获得了多少点击量。
I should have checked. That's crazy that it was on there. But Judd was really, Judd didn't directed, Michael Showalter directed it, but Judd really, really taught us how to write on that movie. We wrote it for three years and, you know, he would rip apart every draft until we got one that he liked. Talk to me about Emily auditioning to play herself and not getting the part and Zoe taking it.
我本该查一下的。它能在上面真是太疯狂了。但贾德真的是，贾德没有导演，迈克·绍沃尔特导演的，但贾德在那部电影里真的、真的教我们怎么写剧本。我们写了三年，你知道的，他会把每一版初稿撕得粉碎，直到我们弄出一个他喜欢的版本。跟我聊聊艾米丽试镜扮演她自己却没能得到角色，而佐伊得到了角色这件事。
How was that? Was that a painful process? She just wasn't off book. She was looking at her sides and that's unprofessional. I was like, you lived it. You should know these lines. Yeah. This isn't radio.
感觉怎么样？那是个痛苦的过程吗？她当时根本没脱稿。她一直在看台词本，这太不专业了。我说，这是你亲身经历的。你应该知道这些台词。对。这不是广播。
Learn your lines. Yeah. Yeah, honey. Please. How about some eye contact? Next time. And now a word from our sponsor. Thank you, Rocket Money for your support.
记住你的台词。对。对，亲爱的。多来点眼神交流怎么样？下次吧。现在听一段我们赞助商的话。谢谢Rocket Money对我们的支持。
Listener, do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend about 80 bucks a month on subscriptions when the actual total is closer to $200 plus. That's right. You could be wasting hundreds of dollars each month on subscriptions. You don't even know about. There is this app or very excited about that takes care of all of that for you. And it's called, I said it earlier, Rocket Money.
听众朋友们，你知道你们的订阅服务实际花掉了多少钱吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花费大约80美元，而实际总额接近200美元甚至更多。没错。你可能每个月都在那些你甚至不知道的订阅上浪费数百亿美元。现在有一款让我们非常兴奋的app，它能帮你处理好这一切。它就是——我刚才说过了，Rocket Money。
They're formerly known as true bill, but Rocket Money is just so much more fun to say, right? This app shows you all your subscriptions in one place and then it cancels for you whatever you don't still want. Rocket Money can even find subscriptions you didn't even know you were paying for. You may even find out that you were double charged for a subscription. It takes care of so much. To cancel a subscription, all you have to do is press cancel. And Rocket Money is going to take care of the rest.
他们以前叫Truebill，但Rocket Money这个名字叫起来顺口多了，对吧？这个app把你的所有订阅都集中显示在一个地方，然后它会帮你取消任何你不再需要的订阅。Rocket Money甚至能找出那些你甚至不知道自己在付费的订阅。你甚至可能会发现自己为一个订阅被重复扣费了。它处理的事情可多啦。想要取消订阅，你只需要按一下“取消”键。剩下的就交给Rocket Money来搞定吧。
Let's get rid of all the useless subscriptions with Rocket Money right now. Let's go to rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. Seriously, it could save you hundreds of dollars per year. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. Fill your unnecessary subscriptions right now at rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. I'm not going to say it again. Smartlist is brought to you in part by Thuma. Guys, are you kind of like as bad as I am about assembling like furniture and putting
赶快用Rocket Money清理掉所有没用的订阅吧。快去 rocketmoney.com 斜杠 smartlist。说真的，它每年能为你省下几百美元。网址是 rocketmoney.com 斜杠 smartlist。现在就去 rocketmoney.com 斜杠 smartlist 解决掉那些不必要的订阅吧。我可不打算再说第二遍了。Smartless 部分内容由 Thuma 赞助播出。伙计们，你们组装家具或者把，
together like anything like for me, my, I have trouble putting together like a peanut butter sandwich. I know there's peanut butter and I know sometimes there's jelly, but I don't know if it goes on the outside of the bread or the inside of the bread. Well the same thing can happen when you get like something delivered to your house with great directions and you just can't figure it out. But guess what? Even I figured out how to put together my Thuma bed.
比如像任何东西拼起来的时候，是不是跟我一样笨？对我和来说，我连做个花生酱三明治都有困难。我知道里面有花生酱，我也知道有时候有果酱，但我不知道它是该抹在面包外面还是面包里面。嗯，当你收到送到家里、附带超棒说明书的东西，却怎么也琢磨不透时，也会发生同样的情况。但你猜怎么着？连我都弄懂了怎么组装我的 Thuma 床。
Your bedroom deserves a refresh and now it's the perfect time to elevate the most important room in your home with Thuma. Introducing the bed by Thuma, handcrafted from eco-friendly, high quality, upcycled wood. You'll find beautiful, unique variations in the natural grain. The minimalist design featuring Japanese joinery helps elevate any space. It's super supportive for your mattress, breathable and made to naturally minimize noise and create space. The perfect platform bed frame just got better.
你的卧室该翻新了，现在正是用 Thuma 提升家中这个最重要房间的绝佳时机。隆重推出 Thuma 的床，它采用环保、高质量的回收木材手工制作。你会发现天然木纹中有着美丽、独特的变幻。融合了日本木工工艺的极简主义设计，能够提升任何空间格调。它对床垫有极佳的支撑力，透气性好，并且能天然地将噪音降到最低，创造更多空间。这款完美的平台床架现在变得更好了。
You can now customize the bed by choosing between their original pillow board or their new solid wood headboard. Thuma practice is an intentional less is more design philosophy for the bedroom with clean lined subtle curves and lifestyle enhancing details. Thuma proves that simplicity is the truest form of sophistication. And let me tell you, just to remind you, just to kind of like bang it into your head, it is so easy to assemble. I did it.
你现在可以通过在他们原本的靠枕板或全新的实木床头板之间进行选择来定制这张床。Thuma 在卧室设计中践行了“少即是多”的有意哲学，拥有线条干净、曲线微妙以及提升生活品质的细节。Thuma 证明了简单才是最真实的精致。我得告诉你们，提醒你们一下，为了让你们有个概念，它组装起来真的是太简单了。我都做到了。
I'm the dumbest person on that planet Earth. I even just said the planet Earth instead of Earth. I'm serious. I set this thing up under five minutes all by myself. It's amazing. I can't do anything under five minutes if you know what I mean. Get that feeling of checking into your favorite boutique hotel suite, but at home with the bed by Thuma.
我是地球上最蠢的人。我刚才甚至把“地球（Planet Earth）”直接说成了“Earth”。我是认真的。我独自一人在五分钟之内就把这玩意儿装好了。太惊人了。如果你们懂我的意思的话，我平时做什么都超不过五分钟。拥有入住你最喜欢的精品酒店套房的感觉，但就在家里，就用 Thuma 的床。
And now go to Thuma.co slash smart list to receive a $25 credit towards your purchase of the bed plus free shipping in the continental US. Go to Thuma.co slash smart list. That's T H U M A dot co slash smart list for a $25 credit. And now back to the show. I'll talk about too about like the merging of like, what was the wedding like between with your religious background and Emily's? Was it like all easily accepted?
现在前往 Thuma.co 斜杠 smart list，购买床铺即可获得 25 美元抵用金，并且美国本土免运费。前往 Thuma.co 斜杠 smart list。网址是 T-H-U-M-A 点 co 斜杠 smart list，即可获得 25 美元抵用金。现在回到节目中。我还想聊聊，关于融合，就是你和艾米丽的宗教背景不同的婚礼是什么样的？是不是很容易就被接受了？
Was the, did you put her a priest? Was it like married? She's, you know, from North Carolina, her, uh, well, that's a religion, some kind of Christian. Okay. Okay. And, uh, it was actually so I, once she was taken in the coma, that's when I first told my parents about her.
有没有，你们请了牧师吗？是不是就像结婚一样？她，你知道的，来自北卡罗来纳州，她的，嗯，那是一种宗教，某种基督教。好的。好的。而且，实际上，当她一进入昏迷状态，我第一次把她的事告诉了我父母。
Um, I was like, I'm here. Hey, mom, dad, classic good news, bad news. Um, but the wedding, the wedding was, wedding was smooth. This is what happened. So basically, you know, I told my mom and they were very, very, they were very concerned for her. And then as soon as she was, she would call me like, how's Emily? And then soon as Emily was out of the coma and out of the woods, she was still in the
嗯，我说我在这。嘿，爸妈，经典的有好消息也有坏消息。嗯，但是婚礼，婚礼很顺利。事情是这样的：基本上，你知道的，我告诉我妈，他们对她非常、非常关心。然后一旦她，她会打电话问我，艾米丽怎么样了？一旦艾米丽脱离昏迷，转危为安，她其实还在
hospital for a while longer, but there was a day where we were like, there was literally one day where they were like, and now it's going to be okay. She was in a coma for eight days and now it's going to be okay. And so then she's still in the hospital for another month, but that month every day is better than the previous. And so, and that's when my mom was like, so what are you going to fucking do with this woman? What's the plan?
医院待了一段时间，但有一天我们觉得，真的有一天他们说，现在一切都会好起来的。她昏迷了八天，现在一切都会好起来了。于是，她还在医院又待了一个月，但那一个月的每一天都比前一天更好。然后我妈就说，那你打算对这个女人怎么办？有什么计划？
Like you guys like living together? What's going on? How long have you been? And so as soon as Emily was out of the coma and okay, we went and got married, like on our own, like stood in line at the courthouse and just went and got married, like literally, this is not in the movie because it's kind of unbelievable, but just a couple months after she was healthy, if you see the pictures of the day we got married, you can still see she's, she's recovering.
你们俩喜欢住在一起吗？怎么回事？你们在一起多久了？所以一旦艾米丽脱离昏迷且状况良好，我们就去结婚了，就我们自己，去法院排队直接就把婚给结了，真的，电影里没拍这段，因为这有点让人难以置信，但在她恢复健康几个月后，如果你看我们结婚那天的照片，你还是能看出她还在恢复中。
And I called my mom and I said, hey, now we're married, so you kind of don't really have a choice. I love this woman. She loves me. And I think you're going to love her too if you, if you meet her. So my mom said, okay, bring her by. So two weeks after our, two weeks after our marriage, we went and to my parents' credit, they threw this big, they threw together a big like Pakistani wedding for us two weeks
我给我妈打电话说，嘿，我们现在结婚了，所以你们其实没得选了。我爱这个女人。她也爱我。而且我想如果你，如果你见到她，你也会爱上她的。所以我妈说，好吧，带她来看看。于是，在我们结婚两周后，作为我父母的补救，他们两周后
later. And the first time they met Emily was at our wedding. And it was really like lovely. Her, her, you know, immediate family came, some of my friends came, it was such a quick, quick thing. Is your dad still with us? He has, yeah. Yeah.
为我们举办了一场盛大的巴基斯坦式婚礼。他们第一次见到艾米丽就是在我们的婚礼上。真的非常温馨。她的，你知道的，直系亲属来了，我的一些朋友也来了，一切都进展得好快好快。你爸爸现在还在我们身边吗？他已经，对。对。
Is he a little bit more of an easier sell than mom is? You're talking about getting mom there. Dad is kind of good with most things. Well, it was certainly a good cup, bad cup situation our whole life. And, you know, Emily is, I don't, you guys haven't, you guys haven't met her. She's just so wonderful and charming and just like, oh my God, I'm getting emotional. Just like truly like the best person I've ever met. And so she's sort of undeniable when I knew that if they met her, they'd fall in love
比起我妈，他是不是更容易说服一点？你刚才说要搞定妈妈。爸爸对大多数事情都挺随和的。嗯，我们一辈子都处于这种红脸白脸的状况中。而且，艾米丽，我不知道，你们还没，你们还没见过她。她真的是太棒了、太迷人了，简直就是，天哪，我要情绪激动了。真的就像我见过的最好的人。所以她简直是无可挑剔，我知道只要他们见到她，就会像我一样爱上她。
with her just the way I did. And isn't it true? In addition to being like this brilliant writer, author, person, she was a former couples family therapist, which means like you can't get away with anything ever. She's, she was a therapist and it's actually good because she sort of taught me a lot about myself. I realized, you know, sometimes you don't know like the things you'd like, she'd be like, you're not upset because you can't find your Bruce Springsteen shirt right now.
难道不是吗？除了是一位才华横溢的作家、图书作者、独立个体之外，她还曾是一名情侣家庭治疗师，这意味着你永远别想蒙混过关。她曾是一名治疗师，这其实挺好的，因为她让我对自己的认识加深了很多。我意识到，你知道的，有时你不知道自己喜欢什么，她会说，你现在不高兴并不是因为找不到你的布鲁斯·斯普林斯廷衬衫。
What else is going on? All right. So she was very good at that. My dad is very, my dad's like a real softy, you know, like he cries very easily, which was good for me to see like a man who was comfortable with his own emotions. And I was someone who wasn't for a very long time. You mean what? You mean the definition of a real man?
到底怎么了？好吧。所以她在这方面非常厉害。我爸是个超级大软心肠，你知道的，他非常容易哭，这对我很有好处，让我看到了一个敢于直面自己情绪的男人。而我曾经很长一段时间都不是这样的人。你是说什？你是说真正男人的定义？
Yes. That's right. Yeah. I mean, just this weekend we were there and my dad did through a 70th surprise birthday for him and he can't talk about it without crying. Like he's like, until they get, there were 83 people there. It's really, really sweet. Wait.
是的。没错。对。我是说，就在这个周末我们在那儿，我爸为他自己举办了一个70岁生日惊喜派对，他一谈到这个就忍不住哭。就像他说的，直到他们来，那里有83个人。真的，真的太温馨了。等等。
How long have you been married now and do you guys make a big deal out of anniversaries or is it just like two weeks later? Yeah. This is all very fresh, you know, 15 years. It was 15 years. Wow. That's amazing. And do you, do you make a big deal of anniversaries or is it just another day?
你们现在结婚多久了？你们会大肆庆祝周年纪念日吗，还是就像两周后那样？对。这一切都还很新鲜，你知道的，15年了。那是15年。哇。太惊人了。那你们，你们会大肆庆祝周年纪念日，还是觉得它只是又一个普通的日子？
We wanted to make a really big deal of this one because I was like, I want to have like a big, because we didn't really get to have a huge crazy, crazy like big wedding, you know, the way we wanted to. So 15 years I wanted to do a big thing, but because of COVID and because she, we just have to be more careful than almost everybody else. We just couldn't do it. So hopefully next year, but yeah, we like to make a thing of it. I think these milestones are important.
我们本来想好好庆祝一下这个日子的，因为我想搞个大的，因为我们以前没有真正举办过一场盛大、疯狂、按我们想要的方式办的大婚礼，你知道的。所以15年了，我想搞个大的，但因为新冠疫情，而且她，我们必须比几乎所有人都要更加小心，所以我们办不到。希望明年吧，不过对，我们喜欢庆祝一番。我觉得这些里程碑时刻很重要。
If you do it next year, would you have, am I invited? Yeah, of course you would be invited. Would you come? Of course I would. What do you mean would I come? Yeah. Well, don't, don't be so shocked. A lot of people, myself included, I mean, didn't I say to you will do not invite me
如果你明年办的话，我会，我受邀请吗？对，当然会邀请你。你会来吗？我当然会来。你什么意思我会不会来？对。好吧，别，别这么震惊。很多人，包括我自己，我的意思是，我难道没有对你说过“千万别邀请我
to your wedding? You did. Yeah. But then you, and then you were mad when, when you weren't, you're like, I didn't get an invite. I was like, yeah, I invited. Okay. Well, Amanda didn't know that you were invited.
去你的婚礼”吗？你确实说过。对。但然后你，然后当你不受邀请时你又生气了，你说，我没有收到邀请函。我说，好吧，我邀请了。好吧，阿曼达当时并不知道你受邀了。
Amanda gave me shit. Well, Jason's wife gave me shit that they weren't at my wedding and I said, Jason asked to not be invited. I just, I mean, she's like, he's such a brat. He doesn't have the authority to say that. So anyway, Well, aren't some weddings, I mean, weddings are, sometimes they just, they're so long in the ceremony and you want to know about you.
阿曼达数落了我一顿。好吧，杰森的妻子数落了我一顿，因为他们没去我的婚礼，我说杰森要求不要被邀请的。我的意思是，她就像个，他简直是个小淘气。他可没有权力说那种话。所以不管怎样，好吧，有些婚礼不是吗，婚礼有时就是这样，仪式太长了，而你想了解的是你们。
It's about them. So yes, Camille, if you find it in your heart, if you're looking for extra seat fillers, I would love to come. You've always been a great seat filler, Will. Jason, can I invite you to the anniversary? I'm not coming. Okay. All right.
这是关于他们的。所以，是的，卡迈尔，如果你在心底能找到一点余地，如果你在寻找额外的凑人数的观众，我很乐意去。威尔，你一直是个绝佳的凑数观众。杰森，我能邀请你来参加周年纪念日吗？我不去。好吧。好吧。
Well, then I'll come. I'll come. I've changed. I've, since Will's been in my life, I've changed. I've learned to enjoy big. I just don't like getting invited, as you know, to like one year old birthday parties. That's where I get. I take offense.
那我就去。我会去的。我变了。自从威尔进入我的生活，我变了。我学会了享受盛大的场合。正如你所知，我只是不喜欢收到邀请去参加什么一岁生日派对之类的地方。那才是我真正被冒犯的地方。
Because I don't invite me to your kids. No, I'm not coming. I'll come to your wedding. Your kid. Fine. You're one year old baby. F off. Yeah.
因为别邀请我去你孩子的。不，我不去。我去你的婚礼。你孩子的。行吧。你的一岁小宝宝。滚一边去。对。
Well, Camille, if you call it not an anniversary party, but you're renewing your vows, kind of like a new wedding, then, and if I can either throw rose petals or be the officiator of the wedding, one of those two roles, other than that, I can't. I don't think I'll. I think I probably have to bribe you with like a sort of a limelight situation. One of those two roles. Yeah. Featuring.
好吧，卡迈尔，如果你不把它叫做周年纪念派对，而是叫重温誓词，有点像一场新婚礼，那么，如果我能要么抛洒玫瑰花瓣，要么成为婚礼的主持人，这两种角色中挑一个，除此之外，我不能。我想我不会。我想我可能得靠某种像是聚光灯一样的待遇才能被你贿赂。这两种角色之一。对。主婚人。
Okay. Camille and Emily's wedding. Featuring. Yeah. And I will not take third billing either. It's got to be an and or an or. It'll be Jason Bateman presents Camille and Emily renewing their vows. Camille, educate me on this.
好的。卡迈尔和艾米丽的婚礼。特别呈现。对。而且我绝不接受排在第三位。必须是一个“和”或者一个“或”。那就是杰森·贝特曼呈献：卡迈尔和艾米丽重温誓词。卡迈尔，给我科普一下这个。
A friend of mine who's Indian got married years back and he came in on a white horse. Do they do that in Pakistani weddings? I think they do. We didn't do that because he got married in New Jersey and horses are hard to get on short notice. Sure. But like, I think that's like a big horse heads on the other hand. Horse heads.
我有个印度朋友几年前结婚，他是骑着白马进场的。巴基斯坦婚礼上也有这个吗？我想是有的。我们没有那样做，因为他在新泽西结的婚，临时很难弄到马。当然。不过，就像，我觉得那就像是一匹马头，另一方面。马头。
I could get you one tonight. Where do you live? It was too quick. What color horse head do you want? Oh my God. It's really scary. Oh my God. What color?
我今晚就能给你弄一个。你住哪儿？太快了。你想要什么颜色的马头？天哪。太吓人了。天哪。什么颜色？
What about a honeymoon? Did you guys do a honeymoon? No, we didn't. We really were at that time just did not have money. And so we really didn't do it. I think I would say I would consider our honeymoon to be right after we finished the big sec. We went out of the country and that was it sort of felt like our first honeymoon.
度蜜月呢？你们去度蜜月了吗？没有，我们没有。我们当时真的没有钱。所以我们真的没去。我想我会把那次当做我们的蜜月：就在我们完成那场轰轰烈烈的演出之后。我们出了国，那就是一切，感觉就像我们的第一个蜜月。
We just, you know, we had no money. I mean, really the rings, we got each other. We got them from Walmart, I think for $75 each. And then we did. Years later, we did go and get new wedding rings. But you still have the old ones for fun, right? Shit. Like in a box?
我们只是，你知道的，我们没钱。我的意思是，真的，我们给彼此买的戒指。我想我们是从沃尔玛买的，每个75美元。后来，几年后，我们才去买新婚戒。但你们还留着旧的留作纪念，对吧？操。就像放在盒子里？
No. We couldn't afford boxes, Jason. They couldn't even do, not even boxes. I mean, I lost, I lost my real wedding ring on the set of Burning Love. Do you guys know that show? Burning Love? Yes. Hysterical.
没有。我们买不起盒子，杰森。连盒子都买不起。我的意思是，我在《燃烧的爱》片场弄丢了我的真婚戒。你们知道那个节目吗？《燃烧的爱》？知道。太爆笑了。
Really funny. Ken Marino. Yeah. Love Ken Marino. It doesn't sound like a set you'd want to lose your wedding ring on unless you want to have a real problem with your wife. What kind of set do you want to lose your wedding ring on? That's a great question.
真的很好笑。肯·马里诺。对。我很喜欢肯·马里诺。这听起来不像是一个你想把婚戒弄丢的片场，除非你想和你的老婆摊上大事。你希望在什么样的片场弄丢你的婚戒？这倒是个好问题。
Married Forever. One of those. You know, it's my husband, Scotty's birthday today. Or happy birthday, Scotty. Yes. And of course I sing him the happy birthday song in Pakistan, which is happy birthday. Thank you very much. Well, how do you know this?
永远结婚。那种类型的。你知道的，今天是我丈夫斯科特的生日。哦，祝斯科特生日快乐。是的。当然，我用巴基斯坦语给他唱了生日歌，那就是生日快乐。非常感谢。好吧，你怎么知道这个的？
You've done all, you do research. I'm a fan of yours and I watch your stuff. Thank you. Thank you. Wait, that's really, that's it? That was just, there was a story I used to tell on stage where I went to a friend's birthday party and they played the birthday song on repeat, but it was some weird knockoff Pakistani version of the birthday song and it was just a guy saying, happy birthday, thank you very
你做了所有，你做了研究。我是你的粉丝，我看过你的节目。谢谢。谢谢。等等，就这样？那就，以前我在舞台上有个常讲的故事，我去参加一个朋友的生日派对，他们循环播放生日歌，但那是某种奇怪的盗版巴基斯坦版本的生日歌，就是一个家伙在说，生日快乐，非常感谢。
much. Happy birthday, thank you very much. Over and over. Okay. And then I saw, I saw a monkey fight a mongoose, I saw a snake fight a mongoose. At a birthday party. Yeah. Yeah.
生日快乐，非常感谢。一遍又一遍。好吧。然后我看到，我看到一只猴子和猫鼬打架，我看到一条蛇和猫鼬打架。在生日派对上。对。对。
That was like. That sounds great. Yeah. Who do you think won? A mongoose. Yeah. Yeah. It was bloody.
那感觉像。听起来很棒。对。你觉得谁赢了？猫鼬。对。对。太血腥了。
I saw, I saw Ricky Tiki Tavi growing up. Yeah. That thing. You guys all saw that cartoon? I did not. I don't know that. Wait. Tell me real quick, because before we let you go, Camille, how many years did you guys
我从小看，我从小看《小书虫大历险》长大。对。那东西。你们都看过那个动画片吗？我没有。我不知道那个。等等。快告诉我，在我们放你走之前，卡迈尔，你们做了多少年
do the Silicon Valley program? Brilliant. We did six seasons over seven years. Super funny. Yeah. One of the best. Yeah. Classic comedy.
硅谷那个节目？太棒了。我们在七年里拍了六季。超级搞笑。对。最棒的之一。对。经典喜剧。
I love that, Mike Judge. Yeah. Have you guys seen the new Beavis and Butthead episodes? No. Not yet. It's so funny. The new, there's a new movie that's really good, but the new show, it's episodic. I think it's on Paramount Plus.
我超喜欢那个，迈克·贾吉。对。你们看过新版的《瘪四与大头蛋》吗？没有。还没。太搞笑了。新，有一部新电影真的很棒，但新节目是分集的。我想在派拉蒙+上。
Yeah. One of those. It's so, so funny. I used to watch that all the time. Yeah. I love it. Yeah. I was just like, I just texted him and I was like, dude, this is as good as the original
对。其中之一。太，太搞笑了。我以前经常看那个。对。我很喜欢。对。我当时就，我刚发信息给他，我说，老兄，这和原版
show. You guys like did it again. It's so, so funny. The same voice actors back for the, to play. Beavis and Butthead. It's a guy who does it really good, Mike Judge. They got him. Wait, what?
节目一样精彩。你们真是又成功了一次。太，太搞笑了。原班配音演员都回来了，为，瘪四和大头蛋配音。那个配音真的非常棒，迈克·贾吉。他们找到了他。等等，什么？
Yeah. Really? It's a sound alike. Guys. Camille, you're the best. Thank you for being here. Camille. You're such a funny dude.
真的吗？声音太像了。伙计们。卡迈尔，你是最棒的。谢谢你来到这里。卡迈尔。你真是个有趣的家伙。
Yeah. I'm such a fan of you guys, all three of you. You're so good and your podcast is so funny and I was really excited and nervous to do this. You're a real nice fellow. You were perfection. Yeah. Nice and easy.
对。我是你们三位的超级粉丝。你们太棒了，你们的播客也太好笑了，我来上节目既兴奋又紧张。你是个真正的大好人。你简直完美。对。轻松又自然。
You got a conversational vibe to you. You're not just there to answer questions. I mean, no, he's very conversational. He's confrontational too. He likes to be confrontational. Camille, I'll see you at the gym. Obviously we work out together a lot and we're on the same. I don't know if it's obvious, but yeah.
你有一种交谈的氛围。你不仅仅是为了回答问题而坐在那儿。我的意思是，不，他非常健谈。他也很有对抗性。他喜欢具有对抗性。卡迈尔，我在健身房见你。显然我们经常一起健身，而且我们在同一个。我不知道这是否显而易见，但对。
Program. You're in fantastic shape. Well, you really are. You really are. Yeah. Not Marvel shape. Not Marvel shape. No.
计划。你身材保持得太棒了。嗯，你真的。你真的很好。对。不是漫威的身材。不是漫威的身材。不。
Maybe just a week or two away. Camille, thank you for joining us. Thank you, pal. It's great to have you. Great to see you and just continued success in everything you do. Thank you. I can't wait to see the new season of Murderville. It was so good.
也许再有一两周就可以了。卡迈尔，谢谢你加入我们。谢谢你，老兄。很高兴你能来。很高兴见到你，祝你在你做的所有事情上都持续取得成功。谢谢。我迫不及待想看新一季的《谋杀村》。太棒了。
It's such a great show. I'm sure you guys are fantastic on it. Thanks for having me. We had fun. Thanks, pal. Thank you, pal. Okay. Thanks, Camille.
真是个绝佳的节目。我相信你们在里面的表现也棒极了。谢谢邀请我。我们玩得很开心。谢谢，老兄。谢谢你，老兄。好的。谢谢，卡迈尔。
Bye, Camille. Bye. Nice to meet you. Love you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Easy, squeezy.
再见，卡迈尔。再见。很高兴认识你。爱你们。拜拜。拜拜。小菜一碟。
Easy, squeezy. Like soft and sleazy. I like that Camille a lot. I don't know why, you know, why do you always say such bad things about him? He's great. I love him. I'm such a big fan. You know, I didn't know like I would watch it stand up and like whenever he's on a talk
小菜一碟。就像温柔又轻浮。我非常喜欢那个卡迈尔。我不知道为什么，你知道，你为什么总是说他那么多坏话？他很棒。我很喜欢他。我是他的超级大粉丝。你知道，我不知道，我会看他的单口喜剧，而且只要他上脱口秀
show because I think he's so fun extemporally. Sorry. What was that? Extemporally. Is that a word? Not really, but keep going. But he speaks, I don't know, whatever, but yeah, I know he's just funny off the cuff. I'll say that.
节目，我都觉得他临场发挥太有趣了。抱歉。刚才那是什么？临场发挥地。那是个词吗？算不上，但继续。但他说话，我不知道，不管怎样，但对，我知道他临场发挥就是很有趣。我这么说吧。
Yeah. And a lot of people don't have that gift. And so he's always been entertaining just speaking. So I love him. A nice fella comfortable in his skin, chit chat in a way. And by the way, it works endlessly. Yeah. Like a huge star now.
对。很多人都没有这种天赋。所以他说话一直很有娱乐性。所以我很喜欢他。一个真正处事泰然、喜欢闲聊的好家伙。而且顺便说一句，他工作极其努力。对。现在是个大明星了。
He's a huge star and he works really, really hard and you're right. He's just very naturally funny. Yeah. In such a great, refreshing way. Yeah. How about, I love the stories about like, if you haven't seen him, like you can watch his stuff online or whatever about his family and like getting married and that person who married them and what went wrong at the wedding.
他是个大明星，他工作真的、真的很努力，而且你是对的。他天生就很有幽默感。对。以一种非常棒、耳目一新的方式。对。话说回来，我喜欢那些关于——如果你没看过他的节目，你可以上网看他的东西或别的什么，关于他的家庭、结婚、那个主持婚礼的人以及婚礼上出了什么差错的故事。
Like it's so funny. Yeah. I want to see a stand up stuff. A fantastic guest, just like they all are. Yes. Amen. Hey, Sean, what's the rest of your day? I have to go work out, believe it or not.
真的太好笑了。对。我想看他的单口喜剧。一个绝佳的嘉宾，就像他们所有人一样。是的。阿门。嘿，肖恩，你今天剩下的时间怎么安排？我得去健身，信不信由你。
I have to, let me see, I'm going to look at my calendar. Why do you have to? Are you training for something? I guess I'm going to land on not, sorry, you said blue. And then what's after the workout? We're going to go celebrate Scotty's birthday a little bit. What does that involve? Starting at what time?
我得，让我想想，我要看一下日程表。你为什么非去不可？你在为什麽做准备吗？我想我还是不去了，抱歉，你刚才说蓝色。然后健身之后是什么？我们要去庆祝一下斯科特的生日。那包括什么？几点开始？
Probably like five or six. We're going to eat a nice dinner together. Just us and then. At five. Yep. What is that? What is that costume? Well, it's funny.
大概五六点吧。我们要一起吃顿丰盛的晚餐。就我们俩，然后。五点。没错。那是什么？那是什么服装？嗯，挺有意思的。
I have somebody coming over to help us make a pizza because it's complicated. And then after the pizza, so now it's six, 15. What happens now? Do you lay a sheet cake out in the morning and just raise it all day? I have somebody named Vic. We call her the cake lady. She makes the best cakes. I'll give her your number or I'll give her you her number.
我请了个人来帮我们做披萨，因为这挺复杂的。然后吃完披萨，现在是六点十五分。接下来发生什么？你早上会把一张夹心蛋糕摆好，让它发酵一整天吗？我有个叫维克的人。我们叫她蛋糕女士。她做的蛋糕是最好的。我把她的电话给你，或者我把你的电话给她。
She's the best. She makes the best cakes and she makes these huge cakes and they're like 20 bucks. Huh. I'll bet they're not great. No, they're great. Amazing. So then do you have a cake already ready? Yeah.
她是最棒的。她做最棒的蛋糕，而且她做这种巨大的蛋糕，只要20美元。哈。我敢说它们不会太好。不，它们好极了。惊人的。那你们已经准备好一个蛋糕了吗？对。
Well, it's a surprise. I always put like a funny photo of him somewhere on like, you know, how they scan it on the cake. So then at six, 15 pizzas done, cakes in the mouth, it's six, 30. Now what's the rest of the night after that? And or, or if not, no, but, no, sorry, no, but, uh, is that premiering tonight? It did last night, but we didn't get around to it. All right.
嗯，这是一个惊喜。我总是把一张他的搞笑照片放在某个地方，比如，你知道，他们是怎么把它扫描到蛋糕上的。所以到了六点十五分，披萨做好了，蛋糕吃到了，现在是六点三十分。接下来今晚剩下的时间干嘛？以及，或者，如果没有的话，不，但是，不，抱歉，不，但是，呃，那个今晚首播吗？昨晚播了，但我们没时间看。好吧。
I'm super excited. You guys watching Lego masters. Is that what it was? You're watching Lego masters. Oh, is that tonight? I didn't, I didn't, I didn't record that. Wait. When is that?
我超级兴奋。你们在看《乐高大师》吗？是那个吗？你在看《乐高大师》。哦，是今晚吗？我没有，我没有，我没有录那个。等等。那是什麽时候？
Well, Wednesday is nine o'clock on Fox. Wait. When did it premiere? Last night. It's okay guys. I mean, we, you know, good night. Oscar is getting a lot of play. We're fucking two years.
嗯，周三晚上九点在福克斯。等等。它什么时候首播的？昨晚。没关系，伙计们。我的意思是，我们，你知道的，晚安。奥斯卡有很多戏份。我们他妈的两年了。
Well, but we've covered murderville and Lego masters so far on this episode, right? No, good night. We're open to April 7th, 2023. Wait, wait. So you're telling me that I can see it in April provided I have a ticket and I don't want a free one. I want to be able to buy the tickets. Bye, Oscar.
好吧，但我们这一集已经聊了《谋杀村》和《乐高大师》了，对吧？不，晚安。我们的上映日期是2023年4月7日。等等，等等。所以你是说我四月份可以看到它，前提是我有一张票，而且我不要免费的。我想买票。再见，奥斯卡。
Bye. We'll see you guys next time. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
再见。我们下期节目再见。再见。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjörf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart是由Rob Armjörf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael手工制作的100%有机艺术品。我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，无论你在哪里听播客都可以收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts上的Wondry Plus或Wondry app提前收听且无广告。
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。